this is like super in my neighborhood I
Drive this street almost every day right
now we're headed
I believe church early I'm headed to a
soundcheck for the gig tomorrow it's a
pretty big venue it's my first time
playing it I'm excited to play it it
holds like probably I think it holds
eight thousand people double-stack Diddy
mm-hmm the name la came from well my
name is Arthur my dad is big art big
Arthur so that makes me little art la
there's a point where I had to make the
decision to choose either choose music
intentionally I figure okay since I
can't play drums that's not gonna be a
lucrative living I can just be a decent
voice I wanted to get into sports
journalism that's what I wanna do I was
registering for classes and nothing
sounded interesting I was sitting on the
bus stop and the bus had pulled off and
you know there's like a steam in the
back of the bus that exhaust and I
promise you when that exhaust hit me I
ever heard or thought in my house their
music it has to be and at that moment I
thought I said okay you know what life
is way too short even if it don't work
I'm about to try it this is my basement
it's unfinished
it's a rough kind of the shed area I
rehearsed down here and made happen
which was it's a beginner level home
studio rehearsal space the tissue is for
a flux boom like that
I want to be a drummer what do I have to
do you got to be cool not not not be
cool not like this cool you got to be
like this cool like talk to that
stranger so what's the Hangout keep
shining your thing from me nice be nice
be nice and I think you know when your
stuff it works in your favor if you're
cool
can you play like that you make yourself
an asset toughest part about making a
living as a musician is the feast and
famine when it's good I was sweet when
it sucks it sucks
another wack part the only thing the
only bad thing the only bad thing about
being a drummer specifically this is it
the only bad thing is lugging all the
year round it's a pretty big gig so I'm
gonna play a big kid um everybody who's
well I look up to they always got huge
kids they always playing because all my
friends out of town they always playing
Matt massive drum kids so I could do
that too let me do it it's a lot of work
though a lot of them they got drum takes
they got endorsements and all that good
stuff that's on the way it's on the way
for your boy how do I make a living
my favourite way to make money is
playing drums in the studio recording an
album for somebody I teach in schools I
do private lessons I play at church
in bigger cities with way more gospel
culture people feed families often just
church the church is lit okay now
there's gigs and there shows a gig is
we're like hey we need a small jazz
combo to play in the corner nobody's
gonna pay attention to you as a gig
nobody knows you at the gig okay
gigs are kind of kind of hard sometimes
shows are what you want your friends and
family to come see for example with dim
atlas I play sound set with him last
summer
South Side is a show how else how else
sound filled almost student who's trying
to steal from every single drummer I see
if you're a kid katelyn my student
coming today I'm gonna take all his
stuff and remit it to be mine and it's
gonna be cold games and so like there's
nobody you can learn from caleb is 12
years old
and kayla was my favorite type of
student because caleb is exactly the way
I was
[Music]
it's super close there's something that
you do I don't know what it is yet but
I'm gonna take it I'm stealing it what's
this go up there's a reason why I meant
or because I had fire mentors when I was
growing up that's one thing that church
gave me that's one thing that being in
the black community gave me and I
realized that that's one of my jobs
that's that's why I even teach because I
got a I got a tell all the secrets to
the you I got a tell them there's stuff
that I'm running right now that's what I
have to share with Kayla got want to do
that with me what
[Music]
things I learn from something become in
retrospect you know experiences meeting
people or conversations that Southfield
has provided we're talking an RA okay
just after we shoot NBC grabbing lunch
and just having just nerdy musical
conversations
[Music]
one of my favorite tracks that we did
was a parody track but this was like the
overkill like to do so but even cut it
that was one of my favorite tracks to
work on I like that one
that was a good cuz I that was our first
initial try at it and already set the
whole folder of sounds and when I had to
pull from that folder and that was a
dope one that came together I'll just
like that gave me hope was like okay
yeah this is about the work this is
gonna be tight
psych I can't play
that's never happened before